in other news this afternoon a plea deal  new at noon in the murder of a  California doctor his body found near  Lake Mead one of the suspects is now  taking a plea deal Kelsey Turner has  taken an Allford plea to second-degree  murder that means she isn't pleading  guilty but acknowledges there's enough  evidence to convict her prosecutors say  Turner and John Kennison beat 71 year  old Thomas birchard to death then  stuffed him in the trunk of a car which  was found out by the lake Turner is a  former Playboy model  their roommate Diana Pena has already  pleaded guilty to an accessory to murder  charge that happened back in 2019.